so
basically um with that in mind when i
say computing with fpgas
is to use fpgas to do some computations
that you would generally do on
microprocessors
and uh to explore what the potential is
of this technology
to do such uh computations so
um in order to get started uh first a
couple of
points on why this could be a good idea
or why we would like to do these kind of
things
and uh what i'm claiming here is
basically that
you could have many orders of magnitude
improvement in performance
and in power consumption when using
fpgas as compared to
implementing a particular function on a
microprocessor and i'll show some
examples
of these kind of applications that we
were already
that we already have for um for fpgas
one neat thing about fpgas is that we
have much more degrees of freedom
than we have on microprocessors always a
little bit a scary thing because we
really don't know exactly how to
deal with all these degrees of freedom
how to handle
all the flexibility that we have on this
new technology
an advantage of using them is that you
can just go into a store and buy some
so instead of proposing a new
architecture that is actually
doing something very well and then
having to persuade
all of the world that this is the next
architecture that they should be using
here you can just go into a store buy
these parts and try to see
what you can do with them to compete
with with general purpose
processors in this case a
further advantage of microprocessors is
the regular of of
fpgas is the regular structure so
you have a structure that is somewhere
between memory
and microprocessors it is more regular
than microprocessors
less regular than memory and uh
ideally it should be possible to scale
this technology
much larger and many people have made
this point was a talk here actually a
couple months ago
by nick tridenix talking about various
uh
parts of these aspects disadvantages uh
offhand the first thing that you see
when using fpgas is that
the latency is going to be slower so
you're running at roughly five times
less clock frequency
and um taking this particular circuit
and putting it on an fpga
you'll also realize that it's about 10
times larger
the ballpark figure is that fpgas
today would use about 80 percent of
of their area to allow
all the flexible interconnect that that
they provide
and this is basically wasted area so if
you have a circuit that you put in there
eighty percent goes for the flexibility
that you
that you get with the device so um
if you look at this um uh the
disadvantages
further we see also we have many years
of
compiler development for microprocessors
and programming methodologies and
ways of actually dealing with these
devices whereas fpga is really
are just targeted at this point by
synthesis tools that are
coming from a different field from
implementing
chips and just apply to micro to fpgas
and you get the circuit in there
it's really not a programming
environment what you have
is a design environment that will get
you a circuit
that works perfectly but it will take
you a long time to get there
so if you look at the summary of all
these technologies
we see the availability is uh
very well for uh the processors dsps
and fpgas on the asic if you have a
fixed function either the asic exists or
it doesn't exist so it depends on
what you want to do sometimes you get
lucky and there is an asic that does
exactly what you want
sometimes you have to design it yourself
which is not very useful if you are in a
programming environment where you really
want to get some tasks done quickly
scalability on the ac again depends
because depending on what what you
is that you're implementing uh
processors and dsps present significant
challenges
if you have a new technology you have
significantly more area you have to
throw
a lot of engineers onto the problem and
they have to try to decide what to do
with this
added area how to scale the previous
microprocessor onto this larger area
that you have now
again the degrees of freedom that we had
before fpgas have
a lot at the cost of course that we saw
before
and
the performance and power advantage that
you might have
theoretically lies between the
microprocessor and the asic
so you expect that you would have
the performance somewhere between a
customized asic
and the microprocessor
at the cost of of the flexible
interconnect
so when i talk about computing with
fpgas the thing that i have in mind in
general
is a system where there is a
microprocessor that runs most of the
code
and there is an fpga that has
some kind of optimization to
execute the part of the code that is
running most frequently
and that is tied in somehow
into the memory system and i'm not going
to get into how you can
put these things together there are many
different ways of combining processors
fpgas and memory and lots of people
looking into these issues
but uh yeah that's not what i'm
interested in here so there are
two basic parts of this talk uh first
i'm i'll show a couple of performance
results
and talk a little bit about how people
achieve these types of
performance and why there is a benefit
of implementing these algorithms on an
fpga and the second part is talking
about how we can get
what we've learned from implementing
applications to design a programming
methodology so that anybody could just
sit down write a little program
and target fpgas and get the same kind
of performance
that we get when we sit down the
hardware designer and let him work for a
year and figure out the details of
of a particular application
so here are some of the examples that i
had in mind when i
said before that we have up to 100 times
the performance and people started in
the beginning
doing the obvious thing taking signal
processing algorithms putting them on an
fpga
and showing that for many signal
processing algorithms you can actually
perform quite well compared to
microprocessors the reason why they're
not
currently switching everything from
microprocessors and
to fpgas is simply there is a cost
problem and
you can't really um get the same
cost benefits that you have for a
microprocessor but from the technology
itself there are much more
signal processing applications that
could run on fpga then they're currently
being run on fpgas same goes for most
applications where you have a lot of
data
that you need to process and simply
stream it through an architecture
so if you have this model you have a lot
of data there is a little algorithm that
has to modify this data
it's relatively straightforward to
simply stream this data through the fpga
and get very high throughput this way
you also get around the latency problem
that
that i talked about before where uh you
actually run it five times slower clock
frequencies
so if you have basically pipelining you
can get around that problem
for uh many applications
other applications people have tried in
earlier fpga computing
projects is to look at
encryption scientific computing
various applications there one
interesting one
is an rsa speed record basically the
fastest implementation
of rsa encryption was done by mark chand
in 94
and was being run on fpgas
so using the flexibility that you have
on fpgas actually for that particular
point in time created the fastest
implementation
so this just shows that there is a way
to get around
the five times longer latency that you
have on an fpga
and um the question really arises
how you can generalize this thing to all
problems
so you don't have to hire mark chand to
to do all your
designs or somebody who is equivalently
clever with with his designs
uh another and he is closer yeah
so another interesting project was
looking at graphics and uh we had a
student
at imperial college who implemented um
opengl or basically the open equivalent
which is a mesa library
and was running uh quake basically
accelerated with fpgas
and again it took a significant design
effort
but that's that's again one one way of
using fpga is simply taking a library
implementing the library functions then
having a general programming interface
that uses this library that doesn't know
about fpgas and just
just utilizes the the acceleration that
you get
from implementing this library
two others uh interesting applications
that we were looking at
we're trying to look at
basically two problems one is where you
have applications that are memory bound
they're limited by the access to memory
or the bandwidth to memory
and the question is can we do something
about these type of applications and
two interesting examples here one is to
solve boolean satisfiability
can actually implement the balloon
satisfiability problem on fpgas and get
very large speed ups there some more
details on the following slides
and another way of looking
at the memory latency problem where you
have to let's say follow
particular pointer is a new way to
implement
data structures and algorithms together
as a hardware structure on an fpga
and this way you don't actually need to
go through pointers and go
follow each pointer have the data in
your memory
in this track in the type of structures
that you have in the microprocessor
so there are some examples following
here there's some more detail on the
satisfiability that i was talking about
um basically satisfiability you take a
boolean equation
and you're trying to find an assignment
to the input variables
that will make this equation true so
what you can do is a brute force search
where all you need to do is evaluate
the actual equation that you have
many times over until you find a
possible solution
and using an fpga you can take the
equation that you want to satisfy
put it down into the fpga and simply
evaluate it very quickly because now
it's just a circuit
in your fpgas you have an instant
specific way to
configure these fpgas at runtime
whenever you
get the data from the user
you simply create the circuit put it in
the fpga and evaluate it
as part of your execution and uh
the main drawback here that we've
encountered is
that you can do the brute force search
but
still you have decades of research that
people have done in order to solve
particular boolean satisfaction problems
and these type of optimizations that
have come up with
would have to be adapted to this new way
of solving the problem
so it's very hard to compete with these
optimized algorithms that you have there
nevertheless for a couple of benchmarks
that we've looked at
we've managed to outperform
microprocessors
running the current state of the art in
boolean satisfiability solving
uh basically a tool that is called grasp
that solves boolean satisfiability and
you can see um the five benchmarks that
i show here
the first one hole six you have the left
bar that says
software and the right one that has the
hardware software is the time it takes
for grasp to solve the problem
and hardware is basically the time it
takes to solve the problem on an fpga
the light blue or light gray depending
on your monitor
uh kind of color on the right for
hardware is the time it takes
to generate the circuit and the black
part is the time it takes to actually
run the circuit
so you can see on the first three
benchmarks
there is no time to run the circuit
because compared to the time it takes to
generate the fpga circuit it is really
negligible
once we start to see some speed up you
have a little black graph
black uh piece of this on top there
and so basically for the
last two benchmarks whole nine and hole
10 you start getting speed ups where for
hole 10 which is the largest one that we
put on the fpga
we got the speed up of 100 times
so the main problem is all these all
these
benchmarks that we've used here are
really toy problems
and uh the goal of of this research is
to try to expand this now
to real problems and use it in real
software but this is just to show that
there is a huge potential for these kind
of things
i was talking about data structures and
implementing data structures and
algorithms on an fpga
so we want to avoid the memory ball and
the bottleneck that we have in the
memory
and one way to do that is to implement
the data structure and the algorithm
that we want to run
over this data structure in the fpga
and one standard architecture that
probably most of you are familiar with
is a content addressable memory and what
that really is
is a data structure with a search
algorithm and you can search
the data that is in there relatively
quickly
you can add values and delete values
relatively quickly
and you don't have to think of
the actual data structure and traversing
the data structure in order to do this
computation
so you can take this type of
architecture
and put it on an fpga and whenever
somebody needs
let's say a data structure where you
need to search something
you simply implement it as a call to to
that particular
data structure and there is a similar
or basically a way to encapsulate data
structures in their algorithms
which was worked on in c plus plus
called the standard template library
where you simply say what kind of data
structure you want and
the library provides you with the right
features that
that you want for that and you could
imagine implementing part of these
as specific hardware structures that
deal with these data
another newer architecture
that shows a different data structure
and a different algorithm
is let's say we want to have a graph and
we want to solve the reachability
problem on that graph
usually you need to implement the graph
as pointers and you follow the pointers
and you figure out if you can go through
this entire graph to go from node
one to the second node and here is an
array-like structure
that takes the adjacency matrix that i
have on the left
and you can see for each one in the
adjacency matrix
there is a corresponding or gate in the
architecture on the other side so it's a
very straightforward mapping
now adding or deleting nodes or
connections between nodes is a simple
modification
of the structure on the on the right
and solving the reachability problem is
a trivial
uh problem now because all you need to
do is to set
the inputs of the particular
wires basically set the wires of the
nodes
that you want to check and see if
the destination nodes can be reached so
let's say for example you want to go
from node v0 to node v3
you can start at the upper line
on top here so you have here
we started the top line
on this graph and you can follow the or
gates to see
if there is a path to go through all the
way to
v3 and if you take a close look you can
see that there is a path going through a
couple of or gates
and telling you that v3 is reachable
from v0
and the delay for this operation is
really just a couple of gates through
through the array the
speed up that was obtained here
is in the range of 10 to 1000 times
and main bottleneck here is really the
size
of circuit that you can put in an fpga
and
size of data structure that you can
therefore put in there
so after you exceed the size of the fpga
the problem requires some tiling and
partitioning of the initial problem
and that then reduces a little bit the
potential benefit that you have
another example here is encryption
a couple years ago i was interested in
seeing if there is a
benefit of implementing an algorithm on
an fpga
compared to microprocessor in terms of
power
so i ran this little example implemented
the encryption um tried to
run it on as low clock frequency as
possible
and compared it to the most optimistic
performance that i could imagine the
microprocessor could ever get
i was looking at two architectures here
the texas instruments and the
digital strong arm and physically
figured out
that we could get five to ten times
better performance over power or
[Music]
poor delay product anyway you want to
look at that
now the question arises here how do we
achieve this type of uh
power advantage where does it come from
um
if you look at the architecture that i
used uh simply taking the data flow
graph
and putting the data flow graph into the
fpga
as is fully pipelining it so that i can
achieve
a clock frequency of the data rate
basically i'm clocking this circuit
once for every wave of data that is
coming in
which is also the minimum clock
frequency that you can use
in order to evaluate this particular
circuit
and use very small arithmetic units
that reduce the size of the circuit
and basically create a pipeline that is
maybe 200 clock cycles deep so for one
data item to go through this pipeline
it takes about maybe 200 clock cycles
but then every following clocks actually
get a data item out so you get very high
throughputs
and therefore very high performance if
you look at the time it takes to encrypt
let's say one megabyte of data
looking at uh at the numbers here
we have uh power delay is a function of
capacitance frequency
voltage and delay uh very
straightforward
we reduce the clock frequency to a
minimum
we reduce the delay by having the
architecture that pipelines the whole
thing
and creates very high data rates
and we increase the capacitance because
we're using now an fpga
instead of a very small microprocessor
and for this particular application we
saw that there is actually
uh up to an order of magnitude gain in
doing that
and the question is really to how many
applications this can be extended
and done but this is just to show that
there is a huge potential here
to actually reduce the power so if you
look at the
global picture here putting everything
together we have applications where the
kernel loop or the loop that is being
executed most of the time
is bound by cpu performance and we have
such loops that are bound by memory
performance or
either memory bandwidth or memory
latency so we can split both cases into
bandwidth problems and latency problems
and i've shown you a couple of
approaches for each one of these cases
on how you can obtain competitive or
better performance
on fpgas if you compare it to
microprocessors
so now we get to the second part of the
thought we've seen that we have the
potential to create
high performance low power
implementations of applications now
how do we program these unless it
becomes significantly easier
to access this performance it is really
not
very useful because it takes significant
effort to implement each one of these
that i've shown before
and i'll show a couple of examples on
how to simplify the programming
other issues are also maintenance and
portability
of such codes but that's not something
that i'm going to get into here
in this talk so before i get started
with the programming just to show the
magnitude of the problem we have here
vlsi synthesis
and what analysts think that
that is going on there if we look at
that we see that
uh productivity of the average engineer
in designing circuits for vlsi
grows at 21 a year while
the complexity of the actual design
grows at 58
and that problem is uh significant in
vlsi design
and there is a similar problem going on
when you want to program fpgas because
at the end of the day really what you're
doing is designing circuits
what the second slide here shows is that
actually
the problem is not as similar as it
looks first
while circuits for vlsi
are hard circuits basically circuits
that you design once and you have to
make sure that they work forever
they have to work for all cases they
have to work
for variable temperatures and whatever
people want to use them at
the fpga circuit is a software issue
and you can really ship a product over
the internet and then
ship a bug fix or ship a patch
just as you do for software and if you
find another bug you simply
fix it by shipping another circuit so
you don't need to go through
as rigorous verification and testing as
you do
in the blsi side programming fpgas
is more similar to actually programming
microprocessors when you write some code
you push a button you can download it
within 100
milliseconds and you just go through the
loop of programming trial and error to
figure out what it is that you want to
write
you can have various libraries
that people can write and share which is
very hard in the vlsi world because
there is so much more effort
going into designing all these modules
so if there is a lot of effort it's also
very hard to get it for free while
if it's very simple to build modules or
a little programs
so they're much easier to share them and
and basically
have many more of them out there another
issue is uh
retiming if you want to for example have
a circuit
and you want to change number of
registers in this circuit
for the lsi you really have all the
options out there you can put the
registers wherever you want
versus in fpga you really have this
fixed architecture
where the locations of the registers are
fixed
and you have these registers there if
you want or not so you could as well
use them in just the place where they
are
so the problem is slightly transformed
just to show that
that there are significantly uh
different problems out there when
dealing with programming fpgas as
opposed to blsi
now lastly i have here three points on
what the implications could be on
changing the circuit every 100
milliseconds
and one that i already mentioned is that
there is no verification
or there is no need for verification
because you can simply
try it out if it doesn't work you'll fix
it at some point nobody has ever
verified unix i think
and nobody has ever tried to verify c
libraries
but you simply assume that they're
working until you find the bug you
send in a bug report don't fix it i'll
ship you a working version and you're
done with it
so that's a little bit of
a different environment that you really
have for
designing these circuits now when you
program fpgas
what you have to do basically you have
the flexibility
on the algorithm level the architectural
level and their pit level
and dealing with this flexibility on all
three levels
is what we would try to do inside the
programming environment that we have
so now the task of the programmer when
you look at it uh
what all the things are that you have to
do when implementing or programming such
an fpga
you have to pick an algorithm like like
when you work on a microprocessor
but then you also have to pick an
architecture
or a structure that is going to evaluate
this particular algorithm
and you can also pick the arithmetic or
the number
presentation that you're using where
microprocessor has
integers and floating point numbers
because this this was a minimal set of
number of presentations
that people agreed on that they need we
are not restricted to these in
fpga we could have any type of number
presentation you can have
any number of bits for any variable
which is at first uh a little bit
um difficult to grasp because
you're used to having 16 bit integers
and they got used to thinking well
we'll just pick whatever bit we need and
then we just have to go with
it because that's what my data path in
in my microprocessor
is there is no need to do that you can
actually
specify any bit with and and just have a
compiler figure out
how to build your architecture with the
different bits
that you have in your data
representation
so now we look at what i'm trying to do
here
we look at what c does to a
microprocessor you have
assembly instructions or op codes and
here comes c and says i'm providing a
higher level interface a language that
has
the same types that my architecture
supports
um easy mapping from the language
down to assembly but i'm not going to
keep for example
the number of registers in my language
i'm not going to keep the actual
limitations of my
architecture that i have i'm going to
let the compiler do
register allocation and scheduling which
is something that
i can easily do in a compiler and that
is tedious to do for the programmer
but i'm going to let the programmer
decide if a variable is going to be an
integer
or a floating point number because
that's something that the programmer can
easily figure out
it's not a too hard decision and it's
very hard for a compiler
to actually make the optimal decision in
terms of which data type should be used
for a particular operation doing the
same thing for fpgas
now we don't have an instruction set
instead of an instruction set
we have module generators so basically
we have a huge number of instructions
any module that we possibly could get
our hands on we gathered into our little
database
that's our instruction set and we're
trying to map an application down to
this particular instruction set that is
limited
by the amount of modules that i have in
my module generation environment
now in order to map that down to the
modules
i want to use the same idea basically
having types
and operators on these types so you
could imagine number of presentations
being
the types that are supported where the
width is part of the number of
presentation
and the operations on these number of
presentations can be mapped
automatically by a compiler to the
modules that you have in your model
generation
environment
now i'm working at uh at this one
particular
compiler that is going down to fpgas and
the general concept here is
that we're splitting up the design space
of architectures
into application domains where each
application domain basically corresponds
to particular way of doing computation
particularly architecture
when i say architecture i mean something
like a microprocessor
which is a specific architecture to
implement a particular function
or the stream architecture that i just
showed before
which is a slightly different way of
computing
so once we know that we are targeting a
stream architecture
we can write a compiler that targets
this particular
architecture which is a stream
architecture and knows how to do
the equivalent of register location or
scheduling for this particular
architecture
so you have an infrastructure below that
is basically the module generation
environment
and you can target that multi-generation
environment with
a set of different compilers that are
each specialized
to particular architecture they know
this one architecture and they know how
to map to that architecture
but they have
less concept of which architecture you
should be choosing so choosing a
particular
type of architecture is left to the
programmer
and mapping the algorithm down to that
particular architecture
is being shared between the programmer
and the compiler
looking at the levels of abstraction if
we compare microprocessors
fpgas and a6 here we are in blsi
synthesis we have software that maps all
the way down from an algorithm
down to the gate level has uh ultimate
flexibility and
there are uh levels of abstraction that
the
people have figured out that they want
to go for and
have different tools to do that for
fpgas what i'm suggesting here is to
have the module generation
and the domain specific compilers on top
of that
that map down to this particular module
generation environment
here is the little bit more detail uh on
the c
plus plus class structure that uh that
the compiler is using
just to show the mapping between uh the
ideas before
and c plus plus is a language to
implement these kind of ideas and there
is really a very nice match between
the classes provided in c plus plus and
the idea of modules and mapping down to
these modules
we can encapsulate hardware
objects inside c plus class
and map down to that same way you can
encapsulate an architecture as a c plus
class and map the actual modules
into that class by just overloading the
operators of the different
representations that we have
so i have a couple examples here
before we go into the examples um the
main question that
arises is you have the architecture and
you have a program
how do you define which pieces of the
program
map onto which pieces of your
architecture how do you map your
algorithm down to that particular
architecture once you know what the
architecture is
and the way this is done at the current
moment is uh
for the stream architecture you have
different types of variables
or different kinds of variables you can
see in this structure there is
there are four streams coming in in zero
to in three
and you have uh four streams coming out
out zero to all three
and you have other variables that are
intermediate variables
that just connect the nodes inside of
your data flow graph that we want to put
down into the fpga
and then there are these little worms
that i have between the bubbles
which are denoting fifo's and these are
really
part of the scheduling where we want to
ensure
that all data items arrive at the right
time to their arithmetic unit
so you have let's say an ad that needs
two operands you want the two operands
to get
to the ad at the right time
so here is one example and you can see
there is a hardware integer
that is the type of the variable in and
i declare that to be an input or a
stream into that architecture
i can also tell how many bits i want
that to be
and i can declare various other types
like that
and just simply write a program that
uses regular
c plus class syntax
to describe what it is that i want to
compute
and i've solved the problems that are
really hard to solve
for the compiler which is how to map the
variables
onto the particular features of my
architecture and
i let the compiler do things like
scheduling
and building off the data flow graph
shifting between different sizes of
operations
uh putting everything together the way
that that
makes actual sense and get me the
resulting circuit
another example here a little bit larger
is that the encryption
where i started uh in the beginning by
writing
many many pages of rtl level code to
create
the idea encryption in the beginning
here i can just write
a couple lines of code that give me the
full encryption and i didn't even have
to write this because the definition of
uh
of the idea encryption algorithm is in c
and you just get it down from the web
and all you need to do is to change the
types to basically
set which variables have which
functionality in your architecture
and it compiles down into that
architecture just by compiling it with
a new c plus plus compiler
another example here that shows
a compound arithmetic unit we can
basically build an arithmetic unit that
is much more powerful than the general
add and subtract
for example we can have a rotate
primitive that takes
x and y and an angle and rotates
x and y and we can build a 3d
motion circuit where i stream in three
inputs the three inputs are x y and z of
the point in three dimensional space
and these couple of operations here
simply move and rotate this point to
another position
and i get another x y and z out at the
bottom of this whole thing
the rotate primitive here is simply just
a primitive that i have in my module
generation environment so it's one of my
instructions
and i don't really have to bother uh
with how this is implemented
or why this is actually rotating a point
all these tricky issues
so now a question that arises
is what if there is a loop with a
dependency how do i deal with
the actual problem that i have a
dependency and a loop around it and
there is a
straightforward example here a fibonacci
series
where you really need the previous two
values in order to get the next value
and the delay of your addition is really
what limits your performance
and the way to do that is uh for example
to choose a number presentation where
this ad can be done very quickly
so you could transform x and y x
into a redundant representation and use
redundant
arithmetic to speed up the actual
computation and with this trick you can
basically try to make up for the five
times
slower adder that you have in fpga as
compared to microprocessor
so the microprocessor will just have the
fastest adder available and spin through
it
versus here i would have to use a more
redundant representation use more bits
to represent my number
but then have a much faster execution
so that's one way of of dealing with
this and the conclusion is basically
that our compilers have to now become
experts in arithmetic in order to be
able to do these kind of things
so what does that mean well if what are
all the possibilities all the
uh tricks spells and whistles that we
want to
pull on on this particular issue and
here just a couple that that i could
think of
at the top of my head which is to look
at the number presentation
we can look at the precision and range
that we want to have
we can look at the arithmetic style of
course where we have sequential parallel
pipeline combinational various kinds
and we can look at larger functions like
i showed before the
rotation primitive you can implement the
whole thing and just
map down to a very efficient little
hardware structure that implements a
larger function
and also maybe less significant
but also interesting for these type of
problems
you can take a fresh look at rounding
and overflow modes
and maybe find more appropriate rounding
and overflow modes for particular
applications
now looking at the details here we have
let's say in the previous case we had
just hardware integers but we could as
well have a hardware fix
variable we could have a hardware log
variable
or type we could have a redundant
variable type it could have residue
numbers
and these are all fairly standard
arithmetic methods that people use
in order to design vlsi chips and
we can basically move these type of
methods into the compiler the compiler
can understand how to deal with these
representations
and you simply let the programmer
understand what happens if he uses this
uh particular number of presentation
without the need to actually understand
how i add two residue numbers or how i
multiply uh
two redundant numbers or things like
that
a second point was uh precision and
range optimization we want to find
the optimal number of bits that we
really need in order to represent a
particular data value
and this is uh turned out to be quite a
challenge
uh there are lots of different things
that need to be considered
when trying to limit the number of bits
the advantages of why we're trying to do
this are
basically we could convert floating
point to a fixed point code
which has obvious advantages in
execution speed
we reduce memory bandwidth because we
are now trying to get
less data from the memory we're just
getting the data that we actually need
we minimize the area on the fpga
and reduce the latency for these
particular applications
and we can therefore also decrease the
power consumption
so these are all ways to try to optimize
an inefficient implementation on the
fpga
and once you can optimize
more than you lose with the fpga
you actually have a better
implementation than you have on the
microprocessor
so the direction that we are currently
looking at um
is really to combine interval arithmetic
and something called automatic
differentiation
but that's also beyond beyond the time
that i have here so i'm not going to get
too much into that
arithmetic styles are straightforward
you can pipeline you can parallelize you
can
build a combinational circuit fairly
straightforward
stuff really where really this is the
one that you don't want to use because
there is a lot of control overhead but
all the others are fair game and can be
used to optimize what you're doing
now i talked a little bit about compound
arithmetic if you want to implement a
larger function
one of the problems i said we can have
any bit with but let's say you want to
compute
sine of a number you need to be able to
generate
a 17-bit sign generator
and there is a significant problem how
do you
create the parametrization how do you
generate
a sign generator for a particular bit
width and for this particular
architecture that i show up here
they've basically figured out how to do
that there is a nice mathematical
formula that you just plug in and you
get how many number
how many bits you need in your table and
how many bits you need for
your multiply add and you can basically
evaluate
your function whatever the function is
to a particular precision
now to slowly wrap up here i have a
couple thoughts on
synthetics and semantics that they're
just
hand-waving arguments really but just to
show what
what the ideas are here they're
basically two objectives that you can
have
either you want the language to be easy
to use or you want the language to be
easy to learn if it's easy to use you
assume that the person is already an
expert in using this language and this
is really the most perfect language
to express a particular problem in and
the problem is it's hard to persuade
people to actually learn your language
the other approach is you go for the
most common language that everybody
already knows and you try to squeeze
your problem
that doesn't fit that language somehow
onto that
and see if you can map from that
language that everybody speaks down
to whatever you want to do and in my
opinion which is a little bit biased
here
um it seems like uh the c plus class
approach
that i'm going is really the easy to
learn one where
most people are in no crc plus plus and
we're trying to squeeze whatever want to
do onto that language
where maybe a better approach would be
to use other languages maybe functional
languages or
languages that capture encapsulate more
of the structure of what you actually
want to do
the problem there seems to be or most
people that advocate that
uh have a big struggle in convincing the
rest of the world
that this is really a good way to do
things and that you really should sit
down and learn this new way of
programming and structuring your
problems
on the semantic side uh
we really try needs to map from the
semantics that you have in designing
this architecture down to particular
language
and uh what you currently do if you use
a hardware description language use
languages that were really meant for
simulation
and were kind of
uh cut and squeezed and pushed into
a little box in order to be
synthesizable and
to get the circuit out uh versus
what we really need is uh to get back on
the semantics also to look at uh
is uh of learning them or ease of use
so now going beyond that work
what i've assumed is that we will take a
couple of architectures and try to map
to these architectures but really have
the flexibility on the architecture
level
and the main open question that i see
here is really
given a particular problem how many
architectures are there to
evaluate this how do we look at the
design space we don't even have a clue
of what the number of possible
architectures
is that we could possibly map that to
what we have is we have point solutions
we have
whole fields that go towards uh solving
problems with a particular architecture
let's say like neural networks
there's a whole field out there lots of
people looking at how to solve things
with neural networks
but if you're not in that field you're
probably not going to consider
using it and there's also no way to
quantify
how a neural network is an architecture
compares to now
a systolic array or a microprocessor or
stream architecture any other way to do
uh these kind of things so i see that
really as the main challenge
of programming fpgas to somehow
try to understand what the possibilities
are what is out there in terms of
architectures what is the design space
how can we parametrize such a design
space
and look at how to compute on fpgas
so to summarize um i've showed that
there is a potential to speed up
applications up to 100 times
shown that there is more than one
application where we can actually
achieve a speed up
the main problem are the two little
words up to
and the question is you can get the
speed up up to 100
but how can you consistently get the
speed up
for a wide range of applications how can
you use these kind of things i've shown
one
little example of an architecture where
you have a good potential to do these
kind of things
shown the use of the main specific
arithmetic how you can map
use the flexibility on the bit level on
fpga to actually gain a benefit
or gain an advantage over a
microprocessor and i've shown the
example of a stream compiler
now this little circle down that at the
end of this slide really shows why
i'm having so much fun doing this kind
of thing
and the nice thing about it is that you
can work
on the architecture of what you're
trying to do and on the compiler and
cycle do the cycle of doing this on a
daily basis
as opposed to on a yearly basis as is
done for microprocessors where people
worked on the architecture and then the
compiler guys take over and they figure
out how they compile to
some other features and then they're
being put into the microprocessor and
each
each uh spin around this loop between
compiler people and architecture people
really takes about a year or two at
least
until they get together and can
do something whereas here you have a
very tight loop and you can actually
move fairly quickly
once you know what you're doing thank
got time for you
um as i understand it your fpgas were
originally created for supporting items
and rapid development right now using
the extended duration test
how if at all would you prefer
fpgas to be designed to suit better
your needs than using them for extended
computing
it's really a hard question how would i
change fpgas if i would want them to be
more suitable for computing um
that question is really slightly
orthogonal to what i'm trying to do and
there are lots of people looking into
that
the main problem with that is that you
would have to understand
what it is that you want to create so
it's kind of a chicken and egg problem
and i don't understand yet all the
possibilities of what it is that i want
to generate
that's why i think it's a little bit too
early to start thinking about what the
optimal architecture for the fpga is i
think the way it is now it is good
enough
for for us to reason about what we want
to generate
on these chips once we have a better
understanding of
what it is that we can map down onto
fpgas
it will also be easier to answer that
question so
i think my answer is i don't know
yeah there's a company called salaxica
whose technology is based on work done
at oxford university
and they have a language based on c and
the claim they're making is that c
programmers come up to speed
very quickly on the language and are
programming some very impressive
applications if you were at fccm
over the last three days you would have
seen very impressive
demonstrations of what the key
programmers could do in a very short
amount
relatively short amount of time are you
aware of scholastica's
siloxica's technology and if so do you
have any comments on it
yeah in particular have they solved the
programming problem
um they have uh advanced certainly
advanced the state of the art
in programming fpgas and they are
basically providing a product something
that is feasible today
with today's technology in today's
understanding of these architectures
um the difference between what i'm
trying to do
and what they're doing is that they're
selling a product
that is uh currently
targeted to what people want to do on
fpgas
which is getting people up to speed
quickly to design circuit mass
much faster there is very little
information on the actual
architecture that is being compiled to
which provides
some difficulty for uh for people to get
started also there is
uh not even close to the flexibility
that i was talking about here in terms
of uh
arithmetic and in terms of uh
various other things that i showed in
this talk which would take too long
so the difference between the two
projects is really
that one is more market oriented and the
other one is more
uh research oriented where i hope that
uh what i'm doing here will be
feasible or somebody would pay money for
it maybe in the 10-year time frame
so yeah
when you're trying to come up with a
speed-up figure like that how do you
determine which
process to compare the fpga to
well
that's a good question i mean basically
you pick one
and show the number microprocessors
of a given technology with a given clock
frequency
don't vary that much in performance
you don't have five times different
performance if you run a program
on an alpha versus pentium
it's twenty thirty percent fifty percent
different
so that's why this number has just
really one or two significant digits
uh because i don't care if it's uh 99.5
or or
101.5 it's just to show the ballpark
that there is a potential for order of
magnitude improvement
the actual number at this point is not
meaningful exactly for that reason
yeah your algorithms specifically take
into account
large performance that you get every
time you need
one algorithm where you said you could
divide things up
how do you address um
the idea is that you have to justify
changing the circuit on the fpga by
running the circuit
about 10 times longer than it takes to
actually change the configuration so
that's usually the way it is done that's
why
people like to implement applications
with a lot of data
because you simply gain the
flexibility in time where you can
process one megabyte of data and that
can take a while
can take long enough to justify
reconfiguring the fpga entering it again
so that's why i didn't show too much
about the first couple applications that
i had which deal with
applications that have a lot of data
because this is a rather trivial problem
because you simply take enough you
process enough data to justify the
reconfiguration
so that's why the applications i showed
are slightly tougher problems
where you actually have tighter loops or
you have the memory in there
or uh you have other types of problems
that are
slightly harder to address
your straightens with motivation
yes yes so the stream compiler basically
that that's what it does it streams the
data through
lets the data being streamed through the
fpga to justify the reconfiguration by
having enough data to process
one of the things one of the ways you
get performance increase in this
sort of model is to uh take advantage of
inherent parallelism
uh you're specifying your algorithms
however in terms of
c plus plus which is uh if anything a
sequential language
uh how do you discover the parallelism
how do you map things out
or are you simply really just recreating
the c
plus plus program as a data flow program
in the uh
in the fpga it is really the recreation
of the program
so you take the data flow graph of
whatever it is
that you have and you you just put it
into the fpga as
is and that makes it very simple to
fully pipeline
and it makes it also very simple um
to just handle the control of that so
there is no control overhead there is no
power or
area or time wasted on
controlling that circuit there
essentially is no control because
data only streams through which is
another uh
advantage of this architectural
microprocessors that spend a lot of time
decoding and
looking at instructions and typing
through true but many algorithms
would perhaps decompose into multiple
pipelines which operate independently
and you could get even additional
performance
if you were able to discover that is
this something which you're going to
look at at some point
uh definitely yes
how do you handle loops
well loops the weight is handled now
are being unrolled so you have a loop
and you unroll the loop
in order to create the full data flow
graph
so that's one way of handling loops if
you know how
so basically there are different types
of loops you have loops that
loop through an array
which is basically going through the
array and streaming that array into a
stream architecture
there are other types of loops where you
do something
five times which can be easily unrolled
and then there are again other types of
loops where you have a dependency
between the loops and you have to
figure out when to stop looping
basically you have a condition
on the end of the loop and that is what
i was talking about in the one slide
with
with looking at loops which is where you
need the feedback
inside your data flow graph and you have
to optimize
the critical path through this loop in
order to get your performance up
and this is where you use the number of
presentations
to shorten that critical path no but
then
how do you achieve pipeline
you just wait for the entire task to
flow beyond that loop before you can
get the next task um pipelining is
implicit in in the architecture
you have for example a multiplier that
is already pipelined
like i said the registers are fixed in
the fpga you can't move them you can as
well use them
right after you go through a lookup
table or some piece of logic
you can as well go into a register
because it's already there
not using it is not going to help you
much so
you know already where the registers are
and there is really no
no big question about where to put them
so pipelining is implicit um yes
we've seen that this technology has
tremendous potential for
evolutionary programming deductive
systems is that caught on yet are we in
that age
yes um john koza is is doing
uh experiments uh for a couple years
already
uh evolving all kinds of circuits or
helping evolution
or doing these kind of things so yes
there are a couple papers out
still very in a very initial stage and
and
lots of problems associated with them
but what we've started looking for
what did you think of the ideas that
microdenic was presented
basically uh one way to implement large
complicated systems
would be to swap in and swap out uh to a
fpga engine a a particular architecture
um
well
nick has a little bit more radical ideas
um
to tell the truth i'm not really sure
how i would do that
but i'm always interested to to
see how this would work
any other questions okay
thanks very much